For more than two decades, COPS has provided
American families with something to watch
on Saturday nights. It's also opened a window
into the work of various local law enforcement
agencies. The craziness we see on the air
is just what goes on in front of the camera,
so here are just a few things that have gone
on behind the scenes.
COPS exists because of a writers' strike
In researching his 1983 film Cocaine Blues,
COPS co-creator John Langley went on ride
alongs to a couple of drug busts. His experience
gave him the idea for COPS. Langley also worked
on the Geraldo Rivera-hosted, poorly-received
American Vice: The Doping of a Nation. Despite
the unfortunate association with Geraldo,
Langley was able to come up with a winning
idea. At the same time, Hollywood was suffering
through a Writers Guild of America strike,
and networks had a need for unscripted programming.
This perfect storm birthed COPS, and American
television has never been the same.
Some cities refuse to allow filming
Because police officers conduct serious work,
COPS' film crews can't randomly show up at
any precinct and just start filming. After
all, having a camera crew following you around
all night can be annoying, as well as dangerous.
Langley fought through this initial reluctance
in order to get his show on the air:
"Originally, when we started COPS, nobody
wanted to be on COPS, including the cops!
I mean, it was a very bold idea."
The film crews need to get permission, and
not all precincts comply. Both Honolulu and
Chicago have refused to allow filming in their
cities, even after multiple requests. The
reason for the refusals is that police work
is not entertainment, and COPS "trivializes
policing," according to the Chicago Police
Department.
Producers have been accused of breaking the
rules
COPS made an entire episode out of the arrest
of Dalia Dippolito, who was caught trying
to hire a hit man to murder her husband. The
TV series was filming in the area when the
local PD’s sting operation went down, and
COPS got Dippolito’s signature on a release
form so they could air her arrest. Dippolito
claims the release form was misrepresented
to her, which the police did not deny. The
little lie didn't affect the jury, who still
found her guilty. She was originally sentenced
to twenty years in prison, but her conviction
was reversed in 2014. Dippolito is currently
awaiting retrial. Maybe COPS can film a sequel
episode!
Police accidentally killed a crew member
With all the danger of filming COPS, it’s
not completely surprising that someone has
been killed during production. In August of
2014, police accidentally shot and killed
sound engineer Bryce Dion. The incident began
when a pellet gun-wielding suspect pointed
his weapon at a Wendy's employee, and the
police opened fire. Police killed the suspect,
along with Dion, who was hit by friendly fire.
While police claim the suspect opened fire
on them, the suspect's family claim the officers
were just excited to be filmed, and the tragic
incident resulted from them showing off for
the cameras.
Burt Lancaster was involved
Before the folks at Fox felt COPS was just
about ready to go, they decided it needed
one more thing: Star power. So in 1989, who
was the biggest star they could get? Tom Cruise?
Michael Keaton? Patrick Swayze? Nope. Instead,
Golden Age-Hollywood handsome guy Burt Lancaster
loaned his vocal talents to the show. The
From Here to Eternity star delivered the opening
disclaimer for the 1989 pilot episode, and
that was it:
"COPS is about real people, and real crime.
It was filmed entirely on location, with the
men and the women who work in law enforcement."
There's no word on how much it cost to hire
Lancaster, who hadn't had a major role in
almost a decade. But seeing as how they used
his voice just once, let's hope for Fox's
sake it wasn't a lot of money.
It triumphed over cancellation
After over two decades as one of Fox's go-to
hits, the network pulled the plug on COPS.
But fans of the boys in blue didn't have to
worry. Spike TV soon picked up the show. Now,
COPS can be viewed alongside such dynamic
fare as Ink Master, Bellator MMA, and Lip
Sync Battle.
(dramatic music playing)
Things have never looked better for American
law enforcement officers. And heck, America.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know what you think of COPS...